Bill Barr Donald Trump's former Attorney
General continues to attack his former
boss you may remember that last week
Bill Barr commented on the indictment
having to do with the alleged
mishandling of classified documents when
he went on Fox News Sunday and said that
if even half of the indictment is true
then Trump is toast he also rebuked
Trump's legal teams claims that the
matter should fall under the
presidential records act rather than the
Espionage Act and full Bill Barr said
that if even half of it is true then he
is toast I mean it's a pretty it's a
very detailed indictment and it's very
very damning and these were big
statements of course because of who they
were coming from the top prosecutor in
the Trump Administration for a time Bill
Barr Trump then responded to Bill Barr's
statements by calling him a gutless pig
well fast forward to this weekend this
past weekend when Bill Barr was on Face
the Nation on CBS and Barr is actually
stepping up the criticism he's not
backing down he's now calling Trump a
consummate narcissist who will put his
own interests his own ego above
everything else he also calls Trump a
Defiance nine-year-old kid and a
fundamentally flawed person who engages
in Reckless conduct so there's a couple
of Clips I want to play for you from
this interview the first has to do with
the legal arguments bar decimates the
idea that Trump had the right to take
the records under the presidential
records act and could simply
unilaterally disclassify them without
going through a process telepathically
or otherwise Bill Barr says that he had
absolutely no right to do that and he
had no right to possess the documents
the legal Theory by which he gets to
take battle plans and sensitive National
Security information as his personal
papers is absurd it's just as wacky as
the legal Doctrine they came up with for
you know having the vice president
unilaterally determine who won the
election
the whole purpose of the statute the
presidential records Act is was to stop
presidents from taking official
documents out of the White House it was
passed after Watergate that's the whole
purpose of it and therefore it
restricted what a president can take it
says it's purely private that had
nothing to do with uh the uh
deliberations of government policy
obviously these documents are not purely
private it's it's obvious and they're
not even now arguing that it's purely
private what they're saying is the
president just has sweeping discretion
to say they are even though they
squarely don't fall within the
definition it's an absurd argument so
Barr says it the presidential records
Act was meant to restrict the rights of
presidents not to grant them immunity or
give them more power and it's not even
relevant to this case because this has
to do with national Secrets not just
Trump's daily diary or anything
innocuous so it's not something that
would fall under the presidential
records act This falls under the
Espionage Act and then we get into the
fun part this is when Bill Barr talks
about the possibility of trump becoming
the nominee and becoming president again
and the impact that that would have on
the country let's take a look at this
Trump has you know has many good
qualities and he accomplished some good
things
but the fact of the matter is he is a
consummate narcissist and he constantly
engages in Reckless conduct that that
puts uh his political followers at risk
and and the conservative and Republican
agenda at risk would he put the country
at risk if he was in the white house
again he will always put his own
interests and gratifying his own ego
ahead of everything else including the
country's interest there's no question
about it this is a perfect example of
that he's like you know he's like a
nine-year-old defiant nine-year-old kid
who's always pushing the glass toward
the edge of the table defying his
parents to stop him from doing it it's a
means of self-assertion and exerting his
dominance over other people and he's a
very Petty individual who will always
put his interests ahead of the countries
his personal gratification of his you
know of his ego but our country our
country can't you know can't be a
therapy session for you know a troubled
man like this blistering words there
from Bill Barr but let's put it all into
perspective Barr was also critical of
Donald Trump when it came to January 6th
and the allegations of voter fraud in
the 2020 election he famously would not
go along with the plan to try to
overturn the election results and he
resigned a few weeks before the end of
the Trump Administration but then he was
asked if he'd vote for Trump over a
Democrat and he actually said yes that
the threat of Donald Trump is not
greater than the threat of a progressive
being put into power so Barr believes
that Trump is like a nine-year-old child
he believes that he's a consummate
narcissist he believes that he's someone
who puts his own interests in front of
the country someone who was wrong on the
law wrong on the morals someone who is
presumably guilty of crimes and yet Barr
thinks that that guy is a better vote
than boring old Joe Biden or someone
else who is in the Democratic party
because of I don't know Socialism or
inflation or something like that so I
believe it's useful to bring up Bill
Barr's statements when arguing these
issues specifically with Trump
supporters because if you're in a
discussion about classified documents
and you can effectively bring up someone
who worked in the Trump Administration
to rebuke Trump's own talking points I
think that that can actually maybe get
you somewhere right because this is
someone who actually was an ally of
trump who is just not willing to stand
with him when it comes to this very
issue but that doesn't mean that we're
re rehabilitating William Barr here it
doesn't mean that uh we can point to him
as someone who is morally upstanding and
write about other things it's really
just like the same analysis that we have
when it comes to George W bush because
bush from time to time will criticize
Donald Trump and we acknowledge that
bush is capable of making coherent
points when it comes to the damage that
Donald Trump is doing to the country
while not overlooking the damage that
George W bush did to the country when it
comes to the needless Wars when it comes
to the war criminality
and everything else that he did during
his eight years so that's Bill Barr for
you absolutely he's no hero or anything
like that but he is someone that maybe
you can bring up when it comes to this
conversation about mishandling of
classified documents the fact that even
Trump's own former AG is not standing by
him when it comes to this issue let's go
to a break and we'll be back with much
more of the David packman show right
after this
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamins A and C as well as
magnesium if you keep your diet
nutritionally balanced all the time you
can get everything you need but half of
Americans don't and it can really impact
how you feel our sponsor athletic greens
makes it super easy I mix one scoop of
ag1 from athletic greens into water it
tastes great I get all of the high
quality vitamins and minerals I need
from Whole Food sourced ingredients I
don't have to Fumble around with bottles
capsules individual vitamins and things
like that I just don't have the time you
should see what's going on at my house
ag1 simplifies everything I'm covering
my nutritional bases for the entire day
super easy easy to stick to as well and
dramatically more cost effective than
getting all of these different vitamin
supplements go to athletic greens.com
Pacman for a free year supply of vitamin
D I've talked about vitamin D many times
plus five free ag1 travel packs the link
is down below